موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم افاده مراسل
الجزيره في شمال سوريا بان المدفعيه
التركيه في ريف حلب الشمالي قصفت بشكل
المكثف محيط مدينه الرفعه التي تسيطر
عليها ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وكان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قد
قال ان القاده العسكريين يبحثون تنفيذ
عمليه بريه للقضاء على ما وصفها بالمنظمات
الارهابيه وتامر روسيا بعدم الالتزام
باتفاق السوشي بشان تطهير المنطقه
شنتها تركيا على مواقع حزب العمال
الكردستاني شمال سوريا واقليم كردستان
العراق
وعلى الجانب التركي من الحدود قتل شخصان
احدهما طفل سقوط قذائف على منطقه كركمش
التابعه لولايه غزه عنتاب
قالواني المدينه الى القضاء فسادفت
المناطق السكنيه واطلقت من مناطق سيطره ما
تعرف بوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي
وصفها بالارهابيه
قصف الحرس الثوري الايراني مقر داخل اقليم
كردستان العراق قال انها تابعه لاحزاب
الايرانيه المعارضه
الخارجيه الايرانيه حكومه بغداد
لتحملي مسؤولياتهما تجاه ضمانها بالمقابل
قالت الخارجيه العراقيه ان الهجمات
الايرانيه تعد خرقا لسياده العراق بدوره
طالب برلمان واقليم كردستان حكومه بغداد
بالوفاء بالالتزامها بحمايه كل الاراضي
العراقيه
على فريقه خبراء الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه تسجيل اضرار كبيره بمحطه زبرج
النوويه في اوكرانيا واكد الفريق الذي كان
قد اجرى تقييما لحاله المحطه ان مفعلات
المحطه مستقره حاليا وانه بصدد تقاسم
مستويات الوقود والنفايات المشعه قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخرفه ان الوضع في محطه زبروج يا حارج
للغايه واكدت انه وقوع كارثه متوقع في اي
لحظه وداعت المجتمع الدوليه الى ادانه
الطرف المسؤول عن الوضع الحالي في المقابل
دعا رئيس الاوكرانيسكي حلف الناتو الاضمان
حمايه المفاعلات النوويه الاوكرانيه مما
وصافه بالتخريب الروسي
ابدا مسؤولون في حلف الناتو تخوفهم ان
تكون بولندا هدفه روسيه التالي بعد سقوط
اوكرانيا واكد رئيس اللجنه العسكريه في
حلف وجود نقص في البنيه التحتيه على
الجبهه الشرقيه من جهه الامين العام
للنيترو الدول الاعضاء الى رفع الانفاق
الدفاعي وطالب بالحفاظ على وحده مواقف
اعضاء الحلف
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه
الى بلاده بصدد اجراء محادثات مع بولندا
لنشر منظومه الدفاع الجوي باتريوت بعد
سقوط صاروخان هناك الاسبوع الماضي وعرضت
وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه دعم بولندا
بمقاتلات يورو فايتر وانظمه دفاع جوي
لتامين مجالها الجوي
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]